[Music]
inconsiderate first news oh yeah
submitted by I'm single
lucky you time Domingo ha I'm kidding it
I love being in relationship here's why
here's why you should think twice before
getting into a rebound relationship why
is this the article again because yeah
you should always think twice about you
gotta watch out but you don't all the
ways or the reasons otherwise and the
seasons yeah oh that's why most people
do it because it's like somebody to
comfort me yeah that feels better I just
thought it was talking sense that you
should always be careful about rebound I
did what everyone knows to be careful
but it's like hard to resist yeah easy
for me to resist I cut that [ __ ] off
like a [ __ ] Dookie done what the
relationship well if I broke up with
somebody there's a there's probably a
really good reason why and that means
that if I've already moved on mentally I
can't do it but if I move on mentally
I'm a person
yeah I thought our Yvonne was a new
person is there like your Inbetweeners
yeah oh god that's what it is oh you're
just using something I'm gonna go back
yeah doesn't read out is the other
person that that [ __ ] stupid go back
right it's not basketball basketball
you're right trying to get the rebound
issue no people like those people that
would need a rebound they go they just
want comfort for like and then they're
they most likely were the ones that were
broken up with so they they haven't had
time to get over that it's pretty common
right you speak of my rebound oceans
yeah I remember that feel and it was
like oh man you didn't prepare me for no
[ __ ] damn now God get some new [ __ ]
now you know what I would see though
that was like 16 17 year old Joe you
know but you see those hot-ass friends
that you have here that your
girlfriend's in her [ __ ] life is
beautiful and they get mistreated by one
guy so they rebound to do the exact
opposite what they normally had so they
had like a really good looking dude like
[ __ ] that should they rebound on this
like [ __ ] whack ass dude I mean that
way I can't do it it's like you are a
goddess thank you so much for using me
as a rebound hmm you got ridiculous
yeah so why shouldn't we rebound well I
mean it's not necessarily that you
shouldn't because there are the positive
side effects of rebounds where your
self-esteem goes up your self-esteem but
that's only like if you're doing it
responsibly with the person you're
rebounding with it's like making sure
that they know like hey I just got out
of a relationship I'm not trying to find
anything serious
and then like also it's up to you to
make sure you don't get emotionally
attached to that person that guy when
the other friends are like what the [ __ ]
are you doing with this guy I was gonna
make that joke and I'm like I've been
going in on you today so I'm gonna stop
but I'm glad you read my mind
well you ruined the joke no thank you
anyways I like being the rebound how
many times have you been there you don't
worry about it right I like them I like
them to judge me all right it feels nice
it's like well at least I've been I've
been a rebound rebound like this yeah
she touched my shoulder broke on the
rebound I've been I've been a rebound
and it was clearly communicated but then
like the table's turned around and then
she ended up wanting a relationship and
I was like that wasn't an agreement that
we had
so you so she came to you to get her
self-esteem up and then you destroyed it
that was not in the contract I thought
we were on the same page I was like cool
with it I was like oh yeah cool like you
know like fpf that's what we used to say
in a day FTF yeah and then like I
thought oh cool we're friends but then
there's no commitment that's awesome
he got you with his luck choice catches
feelings you did Chinese sausage
well you both caught feelings yeah
that's why sometimes rebound might be
good right exactly yeah like if you're
both in the same state of mind in the
same situation you both understand
what's happening and like you don't just
use that one person so you're like I
think yeah using people as an ego boost
knowing that you're doing it and you
love the feeling of them being sprung on
you so you could [ __ ] tell the world
and all that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up because you're that's
manipulative
so will you feel when you saw Kitty like
I'm married no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
remember tune it out the light Chinese
people when all of a sudden your life
that's big because Mexican people don't
even say Chinese people we see Chino so
I know you just made it all up
what what are you grabbing it in the air
how about that did ya whatever Simon is
trying to get your fragrance and essence
away from myself why'd you bring it
towards you you actually brought it
towards you though you went like this no
you ain't yeah that's what I thought
here okay good great for later
what a bummer huh I did not hit my chin
don't play that back I'm curious know
why what about the rebound
what now I told you so I told you the
good thing about it well then the bad
thing about it is yeah like if you're
not if you're not straight up straight
up with the person and not only that but
you haven't given yourself time to
really get over the loss of the former
partner and now you're just like
distracting yourself and immediately
trying to get into something with
someone else and you're not really
addressing that with yourself and then
that's when like [ __ ] will pile up and
then it'll spill over and like hurt the
person that you're rebounding with so
that's unhealthy so you just have to be
emotionally intelligent with yourself
and making sure your man that's rough
that's really hard that's so funny
because I think most people know what's
right and wrong it's just like nobody
could control themselves like nobody has
self-control
well emotions are wild man like you like
as soon as you get broken up with it's
like validate me somebody yeah please
need somebody come here and make me feel
worthwhile that's what happened it's a
what side connection song old-school BP
pain no be like with me I was already
like so over that other person that I
was just like I was pretty much like
single for like a while and then Keith
came along even in a relationship you
were single it might hit like
emotionally
like nothing anymore like those like
nothing it was like you're good at
detachment going anywhere like for a
long time I kept trying to break up with
him but he was just had like some sort
of like hold on me Casey you're covering
up with him no the X oh and like I just
could never find the way to like loose
like get out of his grip like I just
that sounds like relationship right
that's how I kind of fell I'm just like
he was a manipulative like he'll use
like you know other things see you're a
different Tiffany now because before you
a weakest [ __ ] and nobody liked you now
your strongest [ __ ] see cuz now if you
could take the now Tiffany and brought
her back then you didn't spin like hey
[ __ ] you I'm out
yeah for sure I would have saved so much
time but then I feel like everything
happens for a reason that cuz then like
the timing Handler a certain way where
like then it led me to KC you gotta make
me that you don't experience the bad you
cannot cherish the good you don't know
what a good man is unless you have 10
losers yes that's what I say you had to
go through 10 losers yeah to find your
winner you're like wow this one's
actually takes care of me and I could
take care of him and it's like balanced
[ __ ] yeah yeah hell yeah it's the best
what was that what was what was the
moment like when you're like oh [ __ ]
this is not a rebound this is a [ __ ]
inbound slam-dunk
oh when did you first notice that yeah
I'm so curious I feel like from the
beginning I kept telling myself like I
kept preparing myself mentally like okay
this is gonna end this is gonna end this
is gonna end and every time I would say
that I would get so sad I would feel
like so like deep deep down even the
first day why were you telling yourself
is gonna end this so sad you know gonna
do that she wanted the rebound because
you wanted to be a [ __ ] I wanted to try
to be it's not it is less she wanted to
she wanted to experiment with her
sexuality I want to be a [ __ ] I just
couldn't like bet never half
that's how I felt like that's how I kind
of knew because I kept denying myself
like feeling and I kept I kept denying
my feelings until finally I accepted and
then he told me the way he felt like oh
did you ever think that you would be
with a asian dude though just cuz you
grew up around a bunch of [ __ ]
Mexican Pope yeah no I did it I just I
mean I don't think I ever thought of
that well shouldn't not the best existed
yet yes roll my eyes for the back that
would did you did you think you would be
what the Asian dude I think I've always
been aged yeah she's always been
fetishizing the asian guys so I just I
never really thought about it like it
was in a calculated move does it doesn't
matter mothballs so much got a Jade
vibrator I'd be surprised
I bet that sounds fun um but yeah I
think I'd be surprised if I didn't end
up with an Asian oh did you think you
Ana with the white girl no I I didn't
even know if I was gonna get married I
mean oh no like like just throughout
life like I'm like yeah maybe but then I
couldn't I couldn't picture the person I
couldn't picture like what I wanted
it was just like [ __ ] good that's all
I'm thinking whoa now you can sex is
good I wonder what it's like with that
girl or this girl and then that's how my
mind was working it was just like dude
can we do that i watch this on a one
porno can we do that can we try that
yeah and then I get bored and I'm like I
don't think we have much in common man
and then I go to the next one and then
actually new next one's like I don't
know and then you know they're like I
don't think we're meant for each other
and I'm like hey I thought the sex was
good though all right whatever I'll go
to a next one and I'm Lassie trash
what's red I didn't get it like I don't
know I think I was just very very
emotionally immature so it's like one is
the the whole like I have such a like
desire to just [ __ ] all the time but
then the other one is like oh I like to
kick it and we like to have fun and talk
damn chess got that maturing as [ __ ] go
Jess
man I'm still very unromantic cuz I
don't know you know so it's like really
I'm learning I'm learning I think yeah I
don't know romance is I really don't
it's pretty simple though huh is it
ideas hard man it's hard as [ __ ] if you
know that person's love language it's
pretty [ __ ] how do you break it down
to these things I think the hard part is
like cuz they're all logic - yeah so
it's like why I'm saying I know I so I
know her love language right but because
I don't speak it it's hard for me to
commune
it's almost like I know she likes
Italian food but I'm a Japanese chef so
how do I make her [ __ ] like
tortellini you know
I know what hers is but it's it's
because even in that comparison you're
still thinking about yourself versus the
other person though because you just
said right now I'm a Japanese it's not
about you so what you just said was very
selfish but I don't know her language
you just said you know what like I don't
know I know
I know what the lane it's like saying
okay no I know it's gone I'm not Mori
I'm just saying that's what every guy
does they go well this is what I like
you've already [ __ ] up now because
you're still thinking about what you
like and not that person first it should
be I know what you like and that's what
it is
so you're still putting your love
language into her love language equation
so you're still trying to figure out how
you can incorporate what you want into
what she wants and that's where a lot of
guys [ __ ] up that's what I did for like
the first couple years so like I had to
learn all [ __ ] I can't do that where I'm
still trying to fit with my way in to
what I want to give her and that's the
biggest difference so if I'm telling
Mariel hey she just wants to hear good
job you know on the on the spreadsheet
you made it for our vacation I can't be
like that's good that's not how she
wants to hear because I feel a little
weird saying it I could be like you did
a great job it's awesome thank you so
much I should just say it like that
so cuz that would be me trying to weasel
in my little machismo like I don't want
to be all [ __ ] sweet so I don't know
how to delete that out of the equation
he's got do a hundred percent one hand
one percent I see yeah so you got to
like learn how to not do that I still
struggle with that till this [ __ ] day
dude and it makes me feel I struggle
with the timing of it or like being
conscious of it because like we live
life on autopilot a lot right like most
most of us were just ourselves but we're
not conscious yeah actions that's what
it is
so when they need that if you don't have
the radar of oh this is the appropriate
time to be romantic or this is the
appropriate time to just listen and not
say [ __ ] then and then I'm just kind of
like living as I go saying whatever I
want and I'm not conscious of it then I
get in trouble because I'm like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah this is the time to do that
yeah I didn't see that it just went over
my head yeah it's hard man because like
like I say this cuz I you know I hear
that because that's exactly what I do
and I [ __ ] hate that cuz I started
feeling really bad I'm iPod the [ __ ] did
I say it like that if I was going to
give her her love language I should have
just done it a hundred percent but I
still had to keep a little peace for
myself and that [ __ ] it up because you
might as well just not have said
anything at all
because it's almost like a double slap
to the face you know what I mean it's
like you're trying but you're not really
doing why'd you even just say it at all
so I'm learning to fix that part about
myself
[Music]
[Music]